this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website hey guys it's max we
just got in the new surface book 3 and
this is the one with a built-in graphics
card and we're gonna be comparing it to
the nail with 13 inch 10th generation
MacBook Pro and seeing which one is more
worth it for your money not only are we
gonna compare the displays the keyboards
trackpads webcam microphone with the CPU
performance we're also gonna take a look
at things like thermal performance
because this is an a tablet form factor
with that processor and also performance
when you're plugged in and unplugged on
the go and much more let's get right
into into our signature unboxing all
right here we go
and Wow okay this thing it feels heavier
than I expected but I guess maybe it
makes sense definitely feel it's nice
and premium all aluminum all around we
have this hinge right here and as it
gets could see doesn't close all the way
over here where it does over here so you
have this gap you can actually see
through it so pretty nice now inside we
also had the charger and as always with
these Microsoft devices we have their
surface connector to charge I wonder if
you can charge through USBC with this
one and we do have a little USB output
which is nice but what's interesting huh
this is a hundred and two watt powered
doctor more than USBC can give you I
like that the surface connector is
magnetic just like apples old MagSafe
which we no longer have and if you
actually open up the tablet portion and
you disconnect it you actually have a
connection right down here so if you
want to ditch the whole keyboard set up
when you're on the go you could still
charge it and use it
comparing them side by side you see how
much larger the surface is not only in
size if we stack them like this you guys
can see that difference the surface is
wider it is taller but also in thickness
there is a massive difference of course
if we detach the display it's going to
be much thinner and that processor is
also built into the display portion as
far as weight the new MacBook Pros 3.1
pounds compared to about 3.6 3.7 with
the surface version that we have
as far as ports the MacBook Pro has four
Thunderbolt three ports full speed you
can attach pretty much anything you want
including 6k display zgp use and we have
one headphone jack where it has the
surface book three on one side we have a
full-size SD card reader which is
fantastic - full speed USB 3.1 ports 10
gigabit per second that is nice on the
other side we have that surface
connector to charge or you can connect a
hub and different accessories and we
have one USB type-c port now this is not
a thunderbolt three port at all it is
standard ten gigabit per second USB see
with video output and I think that is a
bummer because you can't connect an AGP
you or any other accessories like that
we also have a headphone jack but that's
built into the tablet portion now as I
showed you guys earlier when you detach
the tablet you can still charge it which
is really nice but unfortunately if
you're on the go like this you're
missing out on you know any kind of
ports all you have is that connector so
no USBs no USB C and I think that's a
bummer I really wish they would have put
maybe that one USB C in the actual
tablet unit itself I also want to
mention that this thing is surprisingly
light for such a large tablet most of
the weight is in the actual keyboard
itself let's open these guys up the Mac
and nope
no one hand it open come on
it actually slides quite a bit - I don't
know if there's any fee a very small
feet on there come on Microsoft Dell
could do it they have their new
one-handed open hinge
but it doesn't make sense because this
hinge has to support this whole tablet
with everything inside of there so we'll
give them a pass now here's one thing
that I love about the surface book and a
lot of Windows laptops we have Windows
hello
so the MacBook Pro has touch ID nice and
easy you can also use your watch to
unlock but with this we have face unlock
and actually has an IR blaster here
different sensors and I love being able
to open it up and just automatically
being logged in now let's compare the
insides the first thing I jumps out of
me is how much larger is 13 and a half
inches both on the inside part of that
is because of the bezels we have even
bevels all around
even though the Mac does have fairly
large bezels they didn't change it to a
14-inch the surfaces are larger plus the
screen is a three by two aspect ratio
which we'll talk about in just a bit now
as far as speakers they are built into
the sides right here on the tablet
portion whereas with the macbook pro we
have them down here on the bottom which
we're gonna do a comparison in just a
bit and just looking at it it is
refreshing to see a Windows laptop that
doesn't try to mimic the MacBook Pro
definitely looks a lot different I like
how these size actually curve down a
little bit and I think that's to make
the side look slimmer just looks unique
looks a little bit different and I like
it
the MacBook Pro features apples touch by
I know some people hate them some people
like them you're gonna get various
shortcuts on here depending which
application you have open and you use it
to control your standard things like
your brightness volume stuff like that
and if we go a little bit lower we can
compare the keyboards Apple just updated
from their Butterfly keys that people
really didn't like and they were not
that reliable to this new magic keyboard
that should fix that it also feels a lot
better it has more travel I really like
this keyboard now Microsoft on the other
hand they have these keys here they feel
very similar they're large they don't
have a little bit of convex shape in
here
they're completely flat and I think most
people are gonna be really happy with
them just feeling how it types and
doesn't have as much feedback it feels a
little bit maybe more spongy so it's not
as nice as the MacBook Pros but I think
most people will be happy with it moving
down to the track pads we have a bigger
difference here the surface book 3
trackpad is much smaller overall you see
there's a massive difference in size and
it is a diving board design and I've
been playing around it a little bit and
it's very interesting down here at the
bottom it is super easy to click
surprisingly easy the middle is not bad
but then at the top it's almost
impossible to click and that's weird
because some of their other laptops and
other products have a more even feel the
MacBook Pro has apples force touch it
actually doesn't click at all it's just
a piece of glass and there's magnets
underneath and it feels really nice it's
completely even everywhere and you can
adjust how that simulated click actually
feels and
now let's compare to the displays both
are around 13-inch we have thirteen
point three and thirteen point five but
we have a sixteen by ten with the
MacBook Pro compared to a three by two
on the surface which means that we have
more vertical space if you guys see
right here it's almost the same but the
surface actually goes a little bit
taller now as far as the display
sharpness and detail the macro uses
Apple standard Retina display
it's about four million pixels it looks
nice the surface has about six million
pixels and I love the Microsoft choses
displays that are right in between 1080p
and 4k gives a nice blend of battery
life and detail as far as brightness the
surface book three comes in at 315 it's
compared to 500 nits with the MacBook
Pro now that gets a little bit
interesting if you guys are looking at
that top camera the surface book 3 looks
a lot dimmer than the MacBook Pro even
though both are maxed out now just from
the front it's not a massive difference
at least not as thick as that one and if
we look from the sides the surface
actually maintains its brightness better
than the MacBook Pro now the only reason
I'm guessing this is if it's meant by
design if you're using the surface in
tablet mode yo a couple people around
you say you're watching a movie they're
gonna have great viewing angles from the
sides whereas the macro Pro if you're
standing sitting no matter how you
adjust the display for one person your
viewing angles are not going to change
it's going to be great and as far as
reflectivity the MacBook Pro definitely
has better coatings I look really dark
and muted here where this looks almost
like a mirror that's no surprise we saw
that in the surface laptop 3 and a lot
of their other devices so with that
lower 350 net brightness you're
definitely gonna have a tougher time
seeing if your outdoors or in bright
environments and lastly let's talk about
color accuracy the macro Pro can
supports dcpip 3 wide colors the color
accuracy is great and we saw a big
difference there between a little video
clip the surface looked really muted in
its colors this one doesn't show it you
guys don't see a logo right there in the
center and I looked up the specs on this
display it actually doesn't even do 100%
srgb it's closed about 95 percent
whereas the MacBook Pro could do I think
about 25
% more colors so if you're gonna be
doing things like photo editing maybe
editing video you want to do HDR video
the maca pros display is definitely
better for that before we compare the
speakers and the webcams let me give a
shout out to our sponsor
Squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website now is the
time and Squarespace is seriously the
best way to go you can build a great
looking website with literally no web
making experience like we did it doesn't
matter if you want a portfolio a blog
ecommerce or anything else you just
choose a template and customize blocks
of text and images it's incredibly
simple affordable and ours has been
running flawlessly for over two years
now bringing in new clients thanks to
its built in SEO tools why not give it a
shot you have absolutely nothing to lose
you can do a two week free trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.com slash Mac stack or by
clicking a link down below and when
you're ready to launch you will save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain alright and now we're gonna do
our speaker comparison and I'm very
interested in this because the surface
laptop 3 has great speakers but some of
the other tablets have really bad
speakers so it's gonna be interesting to
see put on your best pair of headphones
and let's take a listen
[Music]
all right guys Wow
you heard that we're doing everything we
can to make it as fair as possible for
the surface book the shotgun mic is now
here we're pointing it at these speakers
which helps and let me get this thing
out of the way out of the shot there
that is crazy I went through the
settings I tried different Atmos
settings other settings we tried to web
browsers the speakers are incredibly
quiet just like the surfers go to which
is like a $400 tablet but this is a big
laptop I don't know how you supposed to
watch movies or listen to music on this
machine that's a massive difference you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below
now let's compared the webcam and
microphone quality the MacBook Pro uses
a 720p webcam whereas the surface book 3
uses a 1080p webcam and it looks like it
has a wider angle of view as well now as
far as microphones I could tell that the
surface book 3 has two microphones on
the sides of the camera so you guys let
me know which one looks better and also
which one sounds better down in the
comments section below
and now let's get into performance we're
gonna start with Geekbench 5s CPU test
I'm gonna go ahead and run it
both of these laptops are using the
Intel's tenth generation processors
they're both four core eight threads but
the surface book 3 is an i7 compared to
an i5 but it also gets more complicated
we have a 2 gigahertz i-5 compared to
1.5 gigahertz on the base so it's gonna
be interesting seeing the results both
also have 16 gigs of ultra-fast ddr4 in
Wow look at these results I'm really
surprised I think that might be the
highest score I've seen from this
processor being in other systems as far
as single core the surface book 3 gets
about 80 points more but in multi-core
that's about 18%
higher performance or better score
that's interesting I want to run this
again but let's see what you get if
you're just using the tablet alone and
here we go
looks like the single core went down
just a bit to match the MacBook Pro and
really ran the Mac again on battery
power Mac's multi-core went down just a
little bit but it's the multi-core
performance went down by about a third
1,600 points and you can tell that it's
throttling it when it's in tablet mode
even though I do have it set to the best
performance most Windows laptops
Unplugged will do much better than this
but it's very interesting how cool it
actually stayed and might be because of
these vents all around the tablet what's
it gonna have to say this thing is so
lightweight it's very impressive to be
able to do this we are gonna be testing
thermals here in just a bit but now
let's compare the graphics performance
comparing the integrated graphics the
macro Pro is using metal and it is more
efficient we get just over 10,000
compared to about 8500 OpenCL score with
the surface book 3 and that score is the
same whether it's plugged in or
unplugged
that's just what you get and we
obviously you can use that graphics card
in tablet mode but the surface book 3
has one really special feature and that
is the fact that there's a graphics card
built into the keyboard and that is a
1650 Nvidia max-q Edition and look at
that score right there this is using
CUDA which is also pretty efficient
thirty-eight thousand six hundred
compared to ten thousand that's a
massive difference in performance and
thankfully we actually unplugged it and
we still got pretty much the same score
actually slightly higher when we used it
unplugged now it's still plugged into a
keyboard and there's a separate battery
in here as well but you don't get
lowered graphics performance if you're
unplugged from the wall so that is great
now what about if you want to do some
gaming let's see what the performance is
like using Unigine heaven and Wow I mean
I guess I should have expected this but
the surface book 3 with that 1650 max-q
it gets over three times the frames per
second we have thirteen point six which
is unusable for most modern games or you
got a kick you know settings down quite
low League of Legends works fine stuff
like that but 42
point-9 basically 44 you can actually do
some serious gaming on this machine and
interestingly it's not that much louder
than the macro it's a little bit louder
but we have a separation of the CPU up
in the tablet portion the graphics card
in a keyboard we have a fan inside of
here it overall that works really well
as far as the cooling system I'm also
gonna do a thermal test here in just a
sec but first let me give you guys a
couple of the differences the MacBook
Pro even though has tension in two
processors it does not have Wi-Fi 6 for
whatever reason whereas the surface book
3 does have it and in my previous tests
with a new Wi-Fi 6 router I notice about
double the speed with the laptop that is
able to do that by 180 at the toughest
part of my house compared to about 90
with the MacBook Pros so that may or may
not matter to you now we also have a
difference in SSDs the surface a lot of
them are just 256 gig compared to 512
now standard for the MacBook Pro let's
go ahead and run the speed test and
check out our performance and Wow ok
that's a pretty good difference so as
far as their write speeds the MacBook
Pro is twice as fast and as far as the
read speeds we have about maybe 400 a
little bit over a four hundred megabyte
per second higher speeds now if you want
to get a 512 in the surface you can't
just upgrade that you have to get a
higher an option which makes it cost a
lot more but more on that in just a bit
and now it's time for our thermal test I
have Cinebench r20 open for some reason
I couldn't get into a power gadget to
work on the service book 3 so I'm using
Hardware monitor here let's go ahead and
get started the surface hit 40 watts the
MacBook all hit almost 40
so they're both cranking up at least
when they're plugged in and they're both
at 100 degrees Celsius right now the
surface is actually running at 3.3
gigahertz compared to 2.8 2.9 so it's
actually running a little bit faster but
now it kicked down all the way to 13
watts almost 14 compared to 24 25 and
we're at 1.9 gigahertz 1.8 gigahertz
actually that is very interesting
because we are plugged in
we're set to best performance and now
the surface is running at 70 degrees
Celsius so it allows it to get a huge
burst of power really quick and that's
why we saw these really high Geekbench
five scores that was a huge punch forty
watts but it tapers that down quickly
it's been about a minute a little bit
more the MacBook Pros fans are starting
to kick up the surface is still silent
and it's a twelve point eight watts
there it is I think I'm starting to hear
the fan but it is running really cool 65
degrees Celsius and really quiet but
also slow that is a twist that I did not
expect we're running at 27 watts in the
MacBook it's running hot it is loud but
sauce running fast almost three
gigahertz compared to one point eight at
13 watts so this is not designed the
surface book is not designed for
sustained CPU performance and maybe
that's just because it's too thin to
have some decent fans in here I don't
know and we have our scores Wow a
thousand two hundred and fifty eight I
have never seen one of these tensions
score that low even the i5 versions let
alone the i7 this should be in the
roughly 1700 range you know right around
there our macro cross cord 1679 which is
very low I don't know why it score that
low if you guys watch our previous
videos we've had 1917 and I have 1911
saved over here which gives us a
performance difference of about 50% it's
I don't know why Microsoft is choosing a
slow this down throttle it so much I
know they want to keep it cool but I
wonder how that's gonna affect things
like photo editing video editing things
like that so we'll have to talk about
that in our full review and now let's go
ahead and finish up with pricing
surprisingly the MacBook Pro is more
affordable now compared to last year
Apple dropped the price by about 400
bucks with similar configurations so we
have four 1800s 16gb ram the i-5 that is
outperforming this pi7 by quite a bit in
full performance and then we have 512
SSD now here you can go for the $1600
model and then
and it actually kind of competes with
apples $1,300 model we have the $2,000
model which is sold out it's probably
most popular 16 gigs you have that
graphics card built-in which is great
but only comes a 256 and unfortunately
if you want 512 you have to spend at
least another 500 dollars and so
Microsoft doesn't give you the option to
configure certain things it's sold in
packages now it makes sense that this is
more costly you have the tablet form
factor you have the freedom to pull off
the screen use that as tablet or put it
back on the reverse way if you want to
draw with the display you have the
graphics card built-in batteries in both
so I understand why it is a little bit
more expensive but it is more expensive
and now for the verdict which one of
these should you buy well we already
know that the MacBook Pro is an
excellent overall value other than not
having Wi-Fi 6 it is a really nice
machine Apple lower the price for the
configuration it is a great laptop you
guys could check out our full review
after this video most people will be
served very well with this MacBook Pro
now the surface book 3 is a very
interesting machine it does all your
standard laptop stuff it has a touch
screen display nice keyboard but then
the screen attaches and you can use as a
tablet and then you have a killer
graphics card if you connect it so you
can do gaming it is a very versatile
machine and so if you would like to use
a system as a powerful processor you can
use as a laptop you want to do some
gaming I think this is a great machine
as well there's a couple things that
really bug me I really don't like that
they limited that performance if you
want good CPU performance it slows
itself down and I don't like that the
speakers suck so bad I would love to
watch a movie with this thing holding my
hands in bed with my kids but the
speakers are so quiet I really don't
understand so we're gonna take a look at
that see if we can figure something out
if you guys have any suggestions let us
know down in the comment section below
but if you're somebody that wants extra
graphics power you want that versatility
you don't mind those speakers then this
machine could be a really great one for
you of course we will do our full review
thank you guys for watching we have
links to both down in the video
description below sometimes in sales so
go check that out click that circle
above to subscribe in an able
notification so you guys don't miss out
videos and check out a couple other
great ones right over there this man Max
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]